a
la inmunización en colombia inició este
17 de febrero con las 50.000 dosis de
facer el proceso ha sido fuertemente
criticado por su lentitud y por lo que
algunas autoridades locales han
calificado de exceso de burocracia pese
a que el presidente iván duque calificó
la campaña como un plan masivo durante
la primera jornada llevada a cabo
únicamente en dos departamentos de la
costa solo 18 personas recibieron su
dosis lo que despertó críticas debido a
la complejidad en el transporte del
fármaco que implica una importante tarea
logística desde bogotá lugar donde
aterrizaron y adonde continuarán
llegando las demás vacunas de igual
forma ha habido una reprobación
generalizada al protagonismo que le ha
imprimido el gobierno pues en la segunda
jornada envió a altos funcionarios a las
ciudades capitales donde comenzó el
proceso lo que en algunos lugares hizo
que se demorarán las inoculaciones las
críticas también se han producido porque
al departamento del amazonas donde se
identificaron los primeros contagios con
la variante brasileña sólo se le
adjudicaron 54 dosis se prevé que el
proceso se vea reforzado con la llegada
de 192 mil dosis de la china corona bach
y 50 mil más de facer
[Música]
es necesario romper la primera fase del
proceso de vacunación contra el kobe 19
con las primeras dosis de la vacuna ruso
sputnik ve luego que inicio de la semana
pasada a la nación caribeña recibirá
100.000 dosis tras la firma de un
contrato con rusia personal sanitario o
brigadistas trabajadores sociales
cuerpos de seguridad y autoridades que
hacen trabajo de calle entre ellos
gobernadores alcaldes y diputados a la
asamblea nacional serán los primeros en
ser inmunizados la vacunación masiva ha
sido planificada para el mes de abril el
presidente nicolás maduro ha asegurado
que en este primer cuatrimestre del año
llegarán progresivamente más de 10
millones de vacunas compradas a rusia
también ha detallado que la inversión de
su gobierno fue de 200 millones de
dólares la administración de maduro
lleva adelante una negociación con la
oposición para acceder a la plataforma
kóvacs y adquirir otros 15 millones de
vacunas en el mercado internacional el
gobierno venezolano ha insistido que se
le está dificultando obtener recursos
debido a que varios países entre ellos
reino unido portugal españa y eeuu le
tienen congelados al menos 300 millones
de dólares en capitales
uruguay será uno de los últimos países
en recibir vacunas contra el kobe 19 de
sudamérica el ministerio de salud
pública de este país indicó que las
mismas llegarían en el mes de marzo
uruguay llegó a acuerdos con los
laboratorios pzifer sinovac y recibirá
dosis de astrazéneca a través del fondo
kóvacs de la organización panamericana
de la salud 165 mil personas recibirán
las vacunas en la primera etapa estas
eran personal de salud de los
geriátricos y del sistema educativo la
vacunación no será obligatoria y se le
pidiera a las personas que firmen un
consentimiento los expertos indicaron
que esto no facilitará la inmunización
de rebaño pero sí permitirá que se
apliquen los contagios en un país donde
el contagio ya es comunitario la
oposición criticó fuertemente al
gobierno diciendo que se tomaron las
medidas muy lentas y de forma tardía e
incluso criticó que hasta el momento no
se ha comprado la vacuna
incluso cuando este país ofreció que se
fabricarán en uruguay
[Música]